friendship is not a transaction you know  you don't we none of us keep notebooks  in our back pockets  with all the things that our friends  have done for us you know  and then when they ask us to do  something they're like well you know  i've done four things for you  this month and you've only done three  so i don't believe i owe you anything  [Laughter]  that's not what friendship is friendship  means um  i could do a thousand things for someone  and they do nothing for me  but i walk around with the absolute  absolute confidence that the one day  that i need something i know without a  shadow of a doubt they'll be there  it's not it's not an equation and it's  not a transaction  it's a feeling and the way you get that  feeling is  with investing you invest in that  friendship and  you build the confidence that they'll be  there for you and if you don't have the  confidence  i strongly suggest you have a very  uncomfortable conversation with your  [Music]  friend